[Music]
in coffee crisis news that had that this
morning my Keurig thinks that it doesn't
have water but it has a whole thing of
water does not work yeah so not working
you can get a new machine like so easy
from most a problem if you tell them you
have a problem with your machine they'll
[ __ ] send you one right away because
they make the money on the pods I used
to have one yeah and it broke that's one
thing we don't have you think about it
it's like 100 something for a carry but
and that's a cheap way to do it I feel
don't tell Keurig that we're gonna do
because they're not gonna know no they
know that they want you to have the
machine so that you could buy overpriced
pods you feel guilty you use a carrot I
do every time I buy a whole nother
shipment of coffee I'm like [ __ ] all
this has to go in the dress yeah it's
kind of wait it's a lot and I wish that
they I mean maybe I want to know if
there is this thing I just haven't the
refillable thing yeah do they have it
okay I need to get that you didn't put
your any coffee you want to which is
cool cause like if you go we have it
here I bought it for this office it's
like a big one and it has its own little
basket I gotta get that because I feel
so bad every time I throw a pot away but
we got to make Keurig thing works we're
gonna use their pod still so we got a
new machine if you're not watching this
they don't know [ __ ]
it could be someone from Carrie saying
positive jazz email cured and see you
can get a brand new hell yeah after this
video it won't go up I'll wait and
personally don't mind the way so I like
curry so you doesn't believe in ways we
don't even have a curio that I know but
I'm praying for future I might just
think of all the [ __ ] that comes out of
your butt tip and how where it goes in
the ocean and all the Dolphins and
covers I think you can handle throwing
cake up in the plastic I know it's gonna
harm the sea turtle no goes right to
this convenient that's what we have it
goes in the sea turtles mouth and goes
right are fighting with the troll it
makes no sense to fight with the troll
this is like fighting with the internet
commenter real-life one thanks for the
practice your bet I get the practice a
lot
so you're so good with your will you
come back submitted by I need it Oh
what does I might need it you goddamn
you tell me yep I'm sold
I need some pain meds coffee I don't
give a [ __ ] for sure it's good no you do
you've been so great we gotta compete we
gotta pee you're so cute you're cute
okay now you guys kiss me I don't like
lesbian [ __ ] no hugs you thought I was
a porcupine this [ __ ] over yeah yeah I
can see no I just want to give them
[ __ ] material I'll hug you off-camera
oh there you go and then I'll kiss you
off-camera the future of coffee is
questioned as 60% of the plants are at
risk of extinction 60% of the plants but
like in in like one bill you just if you
just have one you could grow a bunch
more basically everything has a seed
that you can turn into more we talked
about yeah how is it going it's extinct
so there we're talking about wild coffee
and if it does then I could just keep a
coffee bean and had the key to all
future coffee and run an empire ten
years ago they said the same [ __ ] about
chocolate cuz they said cocoa beans was
[ __ ] and guess what it's fine is it
cuz I still hear it yeah like the Ray
has a grown a rainforest or something
right yes ten years ago they said that
the Alaskan glaciers will only have four
more years left guess what only four
forty really said four and I was like I
gotta go see those glaciers now and I
remember that Al Gore documentary he's
like Paisley the Arctic is completely
elf [ __ ] in ten years and now have you
seen it it's pretty fun it's not isn't
it like half of what it was no it
actually thickened and actually
thickened look it up NOAA research bud
it looks the same on the map that I have
oh do people care about the wild coffee
plants yeah well I think most coffee we
get is wild coffee I think it's grown in
wherever Columbia or whatever
yeah Ethiopia is where Arabica beans
come from
don't name so they're saying that there
there are 124 types of wild coffee 75
are at risk of extinction about 35 of
those species grow in areas with no
conservation protection oh they got a
mate with each other so they can make
more coffees we're just gonna be
drinking the other shitty brands of
coffee all coffees gonna start tasting
like Starbucks mine's all donut shop
shop coffee we're gonna be they're gonna
be hydroponically growing that [ __ ]
don't anybody worry if an industry is
ever threatened they find a way to make
more that the people in Ethiopia they
may have a girl wherever the [ __ ] coffee
grows I don't know but they're not gonna
have jobs anymore Colombia Colombia like
it's all gonna be hydroponically grown
probably in a bar yeah and the price is
gonna be crazy
later and within the ex quit like the
exquisite like rare original coffee
beans will be really be a whole nother
industry it's like instead of eating
fish from the ocean we're eating [ __ ]
farm fish which is disgusting yeah but
look what you pay for like a sick fish
they're pretty yummy look what you pay
for like a sick ass founder or whatever
as in sick as in like I said oh no dope
dope dope species of fish oh what the
[ __ ]
I don't understand like sick si Q sick
like powder that has the eyes almost
it's like it's gone yeah so sick it's
gone
that's a flounder a founder is a flat
fish that lives on the bottom of the
ocean he has both of his eyes on one
side of your face isn't that a halibut
no it's a flounder is a yellow fish that
can talk like a human
I just thought blue planet with Isaac
and they talked about that we have them
in the Gulf of Mexico Mexico they have
vocal cords are the pretty good thing
they're [ __ ] Bob I get him really
like in the wintertime they do they have
Gulf Fathers she doesn't sing in that
movie does he yes he does he talks he
sounds like John Candy sound like John
Candy when the dark if you listen to it
so anyway so they're saying that the
future looks especially grandma for
Arabica which is one of the most popular
kinds of coffee commercial production
they're saying that while the Ethiopian
is [ __ ] it up wild
Vica could be extinct by 2080 who's
[ __ ] up the rapid glance has the troll
in this video I wish I said that I'm not
gonna be around who's [ __ ] up their
land you would be like 92 there's a lot
of 90 year olds that are still alive huh
what's her name she looks good looks
close I can't even like sit still for
like to say technology girl you're all
set alright all live tonight it's Betty
White said that lady to where it's like
it's like what did she been doing
diet-wise and she's like I smoked 10
packs of cigarettes a day I drink every
night it was good Jean you know to me
it's just like that for some people it's
crazy and here you are we'll see who
lasts longer Gio it'll be you spoiler
it'll be you that was a good plot twist
I was already getting ready to like
defend myself I'm like oh [ __ ] you will
make it longer thank you so 15 million
is EOP ins
work in coffee production 15 million and
annual exports have an estimated value
of about a billion dollars so it's
Africa's largest coffee exporters that's
a lot of beans they're not gonna have
any industry if that yeah by 2080
apparently gonna go extinct how is it
going extinct today just because of like
the climate got it and also because you
know I mentioned
35 out of the 124 species they grow in
areas with no conservation protections
to so it's just like sucks time survival
of the fittest coffee
what about climate change is [ __ ] it
up maybe it's not warming up oh wait
we're told us deforestation - that is I
thought I was reading that a lot of for
some reason they're all getting like the
plant viruses or funguses or something
is killing off a bunch of plants yeah
there's a plant diseases that are going
around - that's crazy I didn't even know
plants could good yeah our plants to
have this weird like white pus that
comes out of it all of your plants yeah
quite a few months oh my god no you mean
like if the leaf kind of if you cut it a
little bit no no no you don't have to do
anything it's just chilling and then
it's like white stuff on it it's weird
it's like it's sweating white stuff yeah
in the outside of the inside the outside
oh yeah
I'm like if that's inside your house
maybe you want to take those off eating
[ __ ] diseased plants yeah do you guys
like need coffee survival coffe new yeah
no I mean I do but I can switch at any
time I can go to tea if if you can run
out of it it's not like do you drink it
black I do
I mean sometimes I'll mix in coconut oil
or like a splash of almond milk because
it's if you drink too much black then it
starts making your teeth discolored we
got to drink it iced I like it hot it's
like part of my morning ritual to head
like me too it makes you feel good yeah
I like my morning sip of Monster energy
drink that's all locally grown all local
they don't do that importing [ __ ] and
it's not grown Steve it's created in a
lab why do you want my kids to be
remember this you know what else is
created in lab medicine hope that's okay
how many medicines are killing people
right now
ah did pretty good for me recently what
would you need to learn about energy
drink I'll make you never drink it has
to make your dick smaller what it's like
your kids will come out with defects or
some [ __ ] you can use it because because
I would argue that a tail is not a
defect that would be pretty that's a
sick development that's definitely a
psyche you say because I pictured it
when you women well not the wiggling one
we don't want it the way home BBC
thought pants move that was a good shot
yeah I like that bit yeah like for real
though what would it take I mean well I
don't know what would it take for you
stop drinking coffee because there's
course I am fine with not joking but
it's got carcinogen she's been pregnant
before
no I'm saying but she still drinks
coffee now but I would give up she gave
it up alright yeah I've already done
that well I didn't drink Monster energy
drinks the whole time he didn't exist so
I could really drink diet soda the whole
time not no no no not when I was a kid I
couldn't drink soda was it good okay
riddle me this yes
would you stop drinking Monster energy
drinks for like a minimum of three
months before trying to impregnate her
so that your semen can regenerate
because there you got some hyper ask
kids too you don't want my semen we'll
be extra quick inside getting inside of
her if I
like gonna blow through you girl it's
okay cuz I drink the white monster and
you drinking that's healthier how then
what is its mystery flavor sugar-free
wine that's why that's right and
sugar-free things that are mixed with
aspartame are healthy yeah
dammit I'm drinking miss exactly you do
it you're not taking water that Steve
does not drink water he just drinks
alcohol it and you know what they put in
the [ __ ] water
that's all that's why you have an extra
[ __ ] water filter in your house like
that right yeah we have a berkey water
filter with like four [ __ ] are you
running it through ten times cause it
probably ain't even catching [ __ ]
whatever that is true you can't sit
there I'm just poking holes in you
that's poking holes I mean you can't see
the humans shouldn't drink water that's
not a that's not an art is so deeply in
denial well y'all attack I protect okay
take your addiction no I protect why
y'all attack go ahead protect deep it's
only because we almost lost you and we
have problem is something love I do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]